at a park and ride on the outskirts of
Salisbury soldiers are testing for kovat
19 this is the first of 96 Ministry of
Defense mobile units being deployed in
the coming weeks one of these units is
designed to carry enough test kits for
500 tests a day but by virtue of the
nature of a mobile testing unit it may
we'll have to move to a number of
different locations in one day so that
isn't specifically the target but it has
the capacity to carry that we would
expect realistically to get about 300
tests done in one day and we know that
we can deliver about 50 tests in one
hour quite comfortably these units can
be set up in as little as 20 minutes
those needing a test first check in with
a soldier at the entrance to this
carpark
they're then told to drive around you
can see there's a couple of tents at the
back that's where they pick up the tests
they're handed to them through the
driver's window if there's any problems
they're told to put their hazards on and
they'll come and help once the test is
done they drop it off to the soldiers at
the Gazebo over there as you can see
there's not much to it and that really
is the whole point these are mobile
Rapid Response units which can be
deployed to wherever testing is needed
the units will travel to frontline staff
in places like prisons police stations
in care homes it's welcome news for
staff at Grove Care in Bristol they were
told their nearest testing site was a
125 mile round trip to Worcester it is
so important for us as nursing homes to
be able to have quick easy access to
testing but also quick results so that
we know what we're doing a lot of us
staff team are carers and nurses go into
isolation if they've been running at
high temperature and often we find that
you know someone's been in isolation for
a couple of weeks has made it really
challenging for the team last week key
workers outside of the NHS will also put
on the priority list for testing the
government has reiterated its aim of
carrying out a hundred thousand tests
day by the end of April it's currently
around 29,000 with just four days to hit
that target it could be down to the army
to help make that happen
dan y said Sky News in Salisbury